ok
questa puntata è dedicata
al sesso senza sorprese
c'è qualcosa di strano in questo
libretto
non so bene che c'è qualcosa di strano
questo l'hanno dato la mia sorella nella
sua scuola hanno distribuito a tutti
quanti
ovviamente questo è un opuscolo rivolto
alle ragazze ma invece di dirti quello
che dovresti sapere per non rimanere
incinta qui ti dicono tutto quello che
non devi sapere per non rimanere incinta
tutto quello che non devi sapere per non
rimanere 5 è che la confusione questa
frase scrivete tutto quello che devi
sapere per non rimanere città no tutto
quello che non devi sapere per non
rimanere incinta ciò che più lo più
veloci capisco o che ho capito sono le
cose che non devi sapere per non
rimanere in città ci sono le cose false
ok ok
ed infatti nelle prime pagine ci sono le
bufale c'è le cose che bisogna evitare
di sapere cioè che se ve li dico non
sono false mi raccomando sono false non
è che poi a un certo punto ma arriva la
lettera di qualche genitore che mi dice
che la figlia rimasta incinta perché ha
trovato questi metodi contraccettivi
mi raccomando partiamo con quelle
diciamo meno banali ma farò numero uno
si può rimanere incinta con un bacio mi
raccomando ripeto e sottolineo sono
bufale fini non ci credete solo bufale
solo che poi dopo questa che l'unica
diciamo normale iniziano delle bufale
allucinati c'e chi mai potrebbe credere
una cosa del genere
ma chi mai avrebbe potuto mai mettere in
giro delle cose del genere
del tipo bufalo numero 5 la prima volta
che si fa l'amore è impossibile rimanere
incinta perché ha detto che così cretino
da poter spendere a una cosa del genere
buffo la numero 6
non si può rimanere incinta facendo
l'amore in piedi questa roba ce l'ha
mandata al governo il governo ma fa la
numero 3 se prima di un rapporto bendit
registi non puoi mettere incinta una
ragazza
oppure bufalo numero 8 se fai l'amore di
giorno non rimane incinta perché lo
sperma i ragazzi esce solo di notte
bufala numero 10
una donna non può rimanere incinta se
durante il rapporto non raggiunge
l'orgasmo e queste che di un lettore
erano ancora ancora nella soglia del
ridicolo perché ed ecco allora alcune
chi mai potrebbe credere una cosa del
genere bufala numero uno per evitare di
rimanere incinta bisogna lavarsi con la
coca cola o il limone dopo un rapporto
sessuale bufala numero 4 non si può
rimanere incinta se il rapporto dura
meno di un minuto
questa è fantastica perché tra l'altro
mi è venuto in mente ora se il governo
ha distribuito una cosa del genere è
perché qualcuno credeva queste fesserie
e allucinate bufala numero 9 questa la
dedico a tutti i maschietti
se fai sesso con un uomo che da ragazzo
si è masturbato molto non rimane incinta
perché ha già consumato tutti gli
spermatozoi
in realtà questa è la prima metà del
libricino l'altra metà e spiega come
utilizzare la pillola
quindi non è del tutto inutile a questo
livello facciamo al 50 per cento ma che
si è masturbato a un po ma per cortesia
quindi mi raccomando fate sesso sicuro e
fatemeh tanto tanto tanto